President Trump appeared this afternoon
at a tax event in West Virginia after
ordering the National Guard to the
Mexican border to combat illegal
immigration and drug smuggling he
remains firm on his plans to secure the
border with our military as the
situation he says has reached a point of
crisis you have to have strong borders
we're gonna have the wall we've already
started building it we're gonna have our
wall and we're gonna get it very
strongly the military is going to be
building some of it we cannot let people
enter our country we have no idea who
they are what they do where they came
from we have no idea what their records
are but we're working out systems now
and we called out the National Guard and
you know we're doing a real job but I'll
tell you what the laws of this country
have to be strengthened and tough enough
the Pentagon hasn't determined yet what
the troops deployed will be armed the
move drawing heavy criticism from the
left who claimed this is all just a
rallying cry to the president's base
this president doesn't plan out anything
doesn't coordinate essentially he's
using again our troops as a political
ploy so he could you know again boost
his numbers with his base voters I don't
see the urgency but there clearly is a
political imperative political urgency
might be different than national
security emergency border security is an
issue that won him lots of support
during the campaign and he's playing to
that base again this is more about the
politics given how the wheels have sort
of come off for the president on the
darker side of things when you get Ann
Coulter and many of the very
conservative hard-right saying what the
hell is your problem what are you doing
that rattled him okay Gregg so is this
just a rallying call to the base and
like no juanito said yesterday and
Coulter she runs that she runs the whole
world with the left is there stirred
there's two angles are working right now
the first one is they're calling this
security theater this is all security
theater exactly however it's actually
left-wing activist theater because that
illegal board Craigh border crossing was
manufactured by an activist
group the caravan was organized to
create a confrontation but Trump was
able to stop the confrontation by
creating a metaphorical wall ie himself
saying I'm sending in the army that the
whole thing capitulated and Mexico
cooperated he won this he won this round
in a highly visual manner now the new
media angle is this wasn't a story until
Trump made it one right nobody ever knew
about this caravan well you're
absolutely right
you figured out how Trump works he takes
a story that the media ignores and then
he makes it his story especially like
look at Kate Steinle this is like he
takes something that is very visual that
people understand and he makes it a
national story much like what Fox News
does we tackle stories that the rest of
the media doesn't cover mm-hmm one
follow-up yes ma'am yes okay even very
good so far and I'll be blown away in
two bits in a moment yes
how about the fact that none of the
troops they're saying we're not sure
they're gonna be armed on the border I
don't like that I don't I don't know if
it's necessary I think he's already
proved the point right yeah it hasn't he
already he is a metaphorical wall I mean
nobody liked the way he responded was
all that was necessary it's security
theater Trump's activist theater
okay so Kennedy perhaps they're going to
link arms at the border maybe I mean
what are they doing there and why have
past presidents sent the National Guard
in the first place you know maybe
President Bush was worried that there
were terrorists who were going to pour
over the border perhaps President Obama
was worried because of the the drug war
and the escalating violence and
homicides on the border this isn't the
first president who's done that you
wouldn't know that by the hysterical
reaction or on the left but any time
you're gonna spend a bunch of money like
this you better have a point to it
because when President Bush sent 6000
National Guard troops it cost about a
half a billion dollars and that's a lot
of money and it's money that we don't
have I also understand it's a way of the
president looking like he's doing
something because right now Congress is
not going to give him money for the wall
you know they may give him a little bit
of seed money one and a half billion
dollars really isn't that much and so
this is the only other thing he can do
to show that he's doing
something we also have to ask what kind
of a hellhole is Honduras that's number
one what is going on in that country
that people are leaving in droves and
and taking a very perilous journey
through Mexico the other question is
what is Mexico's immigration policy and
and is the president putting pressure on
them to do their work for that leg of
the journey
okay congressman the president's doing
exactly what he told America he was
going to do if he got into office he
needs a lock down that border and get
rid of the rewards and incentives and
hallelujah he's actually doing it I'm
glad he's doing it and I'm kind of sick
and tired of these people on the Left
saying all this is just you know show
and he's just playing to his base over
the last two years more than 100,000
miners have come across that border and
when you're an unaccompanied minor and
you come across that border guess what
we don't do any vetting to figure out
who we're handing you over to so you got
twelve-year-old girls coming across that
border and we're handing them off to who
knows who yeah and why isn't the left
just yelling and screaming about the
human trafficking and the scourge of
drugs these aren't all people come in to
just you know make life better for their
family this is these are people
purposely moving kids into America some
of them are going into gangs some of
them are going over to perverts you
don't know who they're going into and
it's time that the left actually realize
we shouldn't be complicit in allowing
this trafficking of children such an
important point and it's such a real you
know problem and just yesterday they
made the announcement that ninety nine
unaccompanied minors they're identified
as members of ms-13
were taken into custody etcetera by the
President had them arrested I mean you
really have to be careful in terms of
why wouldn't you I mean it's not
mean-spirited it's looking for justice
and making sure that you do not let
people come in unaccompanied minors
human trafficking gang or or cartel
elements coming in here to do to do
wrong to show that the government isn't
doing a good job vetting either I mean
we can't rely on the government for all
of that stuff and I don't think we have
proper vetting processes in place
because frankly Congress won't do its
job Congress didn't fund more beds so
you can't just continue to
so when you get to the overflow
situation the bad guys notice they have
to just release them and they go out
into who knows where God knows into the
ether one well I mean I I do think this
is theater I don't know
absolutely theatre but it's theater
launched by President Trump at a moment
when he is going into chaos at the White
House he's sending off tweets about
everything he's blaming everybody he
blames President Obama he blames the
Mexican government he blames the
left-wing he blames California in this
situation by the way Greg I think it was
BuzzFeed or
Vice or somebody that first called
attention to it Fox and Friends wake up
on it BuzzFeed Thank You Kenny and then
Fox and Friends picks up then the
President sees it and then he reacts to
it and then blows it way out of
proportion because these people were
never intended to come across the border
except him to possibly apply for what is
quite legal called
guess what you know they wanted some
kind of asylum for you this is all part
of the vilification the president's
warming squirming at 51% it says most
high percent yes in real clear politics
[Music]
election wanna spread lies like that oh
don't spread lies that's a lie
they were one of the tongue probably I
think let me just show you poll that
Rasmussen doesn't is doesn't robocall
polling it doesn't even get people who
have cell phones which at this points
half the country well they're right
the one let's say it is theater and it
might be it might be the president like
I said looking like he's doing something
but there is an effect there is a
perceptual effect and that immigration
illegal immigration has slowed down
since the president actually it's at a
46 year low and in March we saw an up -
there was an uptick however and I think
a lot of these are necessary you have
four border states three of the
governors in those states New Mexico
Texas and Arizona have commended the
president said thank you we welcome the
help we want as much law enforcement
boosting as we possibly can
California is very much on the fence
don't be surprised if there's a massive
resistance to deploying the National
Guard in California and don't you think
that creates the perception that
California is now the place to go
because you like it or not that alters
people's revolt in California continues
with another city voting to support the
Trump administration's lawsuit against
the state sanctuaries laws now today the
president once again addressed the
sanctuary problem take a listen Wan
respond if you look in California and
you see what's happening it's an
incredible phenomena because sanctuary
cities worst
it's basically a city to protect a lot
of people that are bad people
really big okay-y on your response to
this well I mean again this is at all
part the president didn't get the money
in the budget to build a wall he
promised the wall and Coulter and people
on the far right have said hey what
happened to your pledge now we see him
reacting impulsively you point out by
the way these folks have no authority to
arrest or detain any illegal immigrant
Kennedy points out we don't have the
money we're spending money like all of a
sudden oh there's tons of money
nobody has of money they plussed up the
domestic budget by thirteen percent okay
how did hundreds of billions right we
didn't there's any money for this but
they do for the military they go 8600
lien dollars so in other words now he's
changing the terms by the way I noticed
Mexico is not paying for any of this
which was the initial promise right so
to me this is theater but but you
apparently are buying into it so I
respond to the fact that it is not
theater when an actual Caravan turned
around and what you're seeing and this
is very important as an overall trend
when you look at why Donald Trump's
numbers are ticking up and it is a trend
you don't look at the absolute value but
the trend in the Rasmussen poll which is
a legitimate poll the reason why it's up
ticking is because he represents a
certain assumption about law and order
what you're seeing what you saw with
that with that Caravan was the old
school meeting the new school the old
school hardline no BS send in the army
Trump goes up against to the social
justice grievance culture that has been
around for years which speaks of amnesty
and speaks of sanctuary cities and to
quote one guess what he's walked all
over him Trump walked all over it he won
he stood his ground and base and it
arrives me and you know I will never use
the phrase Reaganesque but it reminds me
of Reagan in 1969 when he sent the
National Garden in the riots of Berkeley
and he established you know a curfew and
and he refused to negotiate no one
remembers the negotiators that remember
the people that stood their ground for
America America first not America last
it's working let me just tell you first
of all the caravans and coming up every
year big true several years any set it
back next and the president
congratulated Mexico for helping him
truly oh we've got you know and this is
this is a part of the story that it's
painful to admit but part of the reason
that Central America is decimated is
because of the drug war and it is it has
not done anything committing these
resources has not done anything about
the demand for drugs in this country
like it or not for better or for worse
be careful don't tell the truth like
that are the audience mate with wait now
the truth is 90%
Mexico City you just you said something
different yesterday what I say you said
that heroin is all coming from
prescriptions no no I said that an
overwhelming percentage and overdoses
are caused by street drugs 90% of all
heroin comes from Mexico you dismiss
that know what I'm saying check the
watch they post well I'm just telling
you DEA says most of the illegal drugs
entering this country come through legal
ports of entry people hide them on
themselves
you said you dismiss what Mexico said of
heroin it's handled and at the direction
of the court let me just tell you what
I'm talking about the big threat to us
as Americans at this moment our
prescription drugs the opioids that's
what's killing us as an American people
they're killing five times the number of
people that are killed by cocaine heroin
happens when marijuana is legal in
states where there's medical marijuana
not only are there far fewer
prescriptions for morphine and
hydrocodone
they're also far fewer opioid deaths
that'd be great overdose drops by about
25% get an argument from me the
marijuana legalization Lobby over there
and that into the table yeah and it
doesn't help to demonize people who are
experiencing cancer pain by saying
opioids are evil